This is what I do, just watch me, I'm like this, here, bang, it's on.
You don't have to get in here and wait until you see him because then it screws up.
With you on, with you on.
Ready?
Yeah, hop on.
Yeah, right here.
Good.
Okay.
Yep, yep, yep, yep.
Look, look, look, look.
Check, check, check.
Ah, turn, turn.
Ah.
No, no, it's like us, yep.
It's a shit pass.
But he knows that.
He needs to hear it from you.
All right.
Okay?
I'll get it right next time.
Hey, that was a shit pass.
I'll get it next time.
Great, we're on now.
Holding.
Hey, that was a pass, that wasn't a pop.
Those tens had a bit on you.
I don't know what I did.
Yeah, it's here.
Here we go.
Guys, we're ready.
Get your tents.
Hey, look, make sure they're ready.
Front foot, front foot low.
Wear your hands.
Ready.
Oh, that was a pass.
Yeah, yeah.
The tens would have been all over you, man.
The airframe.
Yeah, I'm with you.
I'm with you.
Tighter.
Good.
Better.
Yeah.
Here we go.
Come on.
Good.
Oh.
Yeah, I'm with you.
I'm with you.
Tighter.
Good.
Right here.
All the time.